make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are continuing on with
annihilation scourge and this is
actually a fun little story it's
self-contained right now mage this is
totally self-contained and these are
some of the stories that I think hidden
oftentimes be the most enjoyable dear
one-offs
right like you get this story and then
done like you set this down and that's
it those of you guys remember that the
first video that we did and I'll link it
down in the description so you can get
caught up if you didn't if you didn't
see it but with the first video that we
did what we had talked about was that
the Avengers basically the various
Avengers out there from the cancerverse
which is a sake as universal people can
never die
where it was believed that universe was
essentially destroyed that turned out to
not be the case instead the cancerverse
had somehow found a found a way to
invade the negative zone right so as a
result of that you had a nihilist who
basically was the leader of the negative
zone kind of this self-appointed ruler
of the entire area it's because his
forces were large enough for him to just
conquer if he had ultimately ended up
fleeing the negative zone and then
trying to find aid and so what this does
is it basically picks up initially with
Johnny Storm now here's the cool thing
is this actually makes references to
Jonathan Hickman's run on the Fantastic
Four and it's one of the coolest things
because for those the guys who read that
run or who saw my videos on it ah there
was one point where like Johnny Storm
died and what was one of the coolest
moments ever in the history of his
character right like dude who's
ridiculously amazing like the portal to
the negative zone gets opened up and
like Johnny Storm basically stays behind
in order to like keep the forces of the
annihilation wave from pouring out so
like you know it's like this really
tearful farewell between like Vin Graham
and Franklin and valaria and so on cuz I
think because they're like Johnny's
gonna die right I mean he's gonna die
fighting like billions of billions of
these guys and so there's there's this
super amazing moment where Johnny turns
around and he's just like alright guys
flame on it's just like dude that's like
Johnny Storm goes out with a bang
right it was it was a craziest thing now
of course he ended up returning later on
but like moments like that or I keep
going back to Jonathan Hickman's
Fantastic Four and reading it
consistently right because I've read it
maybe three times since we first covered
it like three first covered on the
channel I loved it it's just an amazing
story and so ultimately what Johnny's
doing here what he's experiencing is
basically the the nightmares he endured
there right in the sense that like he
was killed and then he was brought back
and then killed and brought back and it
happened over and over again now
eventually he basically rose to like
take over the annihilation wave right to
conquer the whole thing but it's like
these dreams that he has constantly
where he's facing off against Annihilus
being destroyed so on and so forth and
it just repeats itself over and over and
over again so as a result that of course
he's still doing what he's always done
which is like pranking you know Ben
Grimm he puts like he puts shaving cream
on his face
and then like basically like makes it
look like Santa Claus which is kind of
funny but the fantastic for themselves
the basically got like a beacon like an
SOS call from the negative zone so of
course they always have a portal in the
Baxter building
to access the negative zone but
basically like all these various
refugees come fleeing out of the area
now at that point they basically tell us
what's going to be a recurring theme so
we're probably skip it for a lot of the
other a lot of the other parts that we
do here but basically they're just kind
of talking about how like these forces
that just can't die have basically
managed to invade and everybody's just
fleeing for their life is really all it
is now one of the interesting thing that
goes on here is that they're basically
told that like one of the forces here is
the century and initially Reed Richards
kind of takes it on and it's just like
okay so there's some indication by Reed
that like this is kind of his fault
that's kind of how he takes it on that
he believes it's kind of his fault
initially but Reed isn't really spilling
the beans right and so as soon as they
get into the negative zone their first
full array is to come across crystal of
the Inhumans from the revenger whose
face is all screwed up and twisted of
course again that happens by the mini
angled ones they physically mutate you
as well as like turning you into an evil
person and then of course you know they
she ends up almost killing them all and
they manage to like subdue her and then
ultimately end up end up basically
taking off but from there what we end up
doing is getting this explanation and
this is when this is when things get
cool right because what Reed says is
that after the events of Geoff's
Lemieux's run that the century had come
to visit him right like merged century
had come to visit him to say hey look
I'm trying to get myself sorted out and
so what Reed had done is that when when
Robert Reynolds requested that Reed find
a way to remove the void
anytime that's ever happened with a void
in the century have become separated the
void becomes this wildly autonomous and
insanely powerful entity that's non-stop
Abul and so when Reed looked at me said
well there's no real way to do it in our
universe right there's no real way to
separate you and the void from each
other but maybe in the antimatter
universe you can and the negative zone
you can't and so ultimately Century went
in there by himself now Reed offered to
go with a sentry shot him down and so
following that something seemed to
happen that basically led to the
emergence of the revenge's inside the
cancerverse which is actually kind of a
cool and an interesting thing from there
you basically end up running into the
cancerverse version of the Fantastic
Four
now when the cancerverse Fantastic Four
show up here they basically kind of
start taunting the team you do kind of
get this knock-down drag-out fight
between the two where they all start
going at it one of the crazy things is
that Reed has kind of wrapped himself
the cancerous version of Reed his rack
himself around the cancerous versions of
Susan Johnny Storm and Ben Grimm but
they're all twisted and they're screwed
up
and they're evil and and like horrifying
human beings and so what you get is this
almost kind of attempt by Johnny Storm
basically using the the various
technologies of read to kind of force
them to see how their world is supposed
to be right like how the Fantastic Four
and the main Marvel Universe came up as
opposed to the cancerverse versions and
the cancerous versions are subjected to
this universe where things could have
been amazing or what things could have
been fantastic the result of this is
that what seems to have gone on here is
that Reed and the cancer universe had
basically duped everybody else right
saying like we have to join them it's
what's best for us that kind of thing
there's nothing that we can do there's
no hope for anything like that when it
was in reality it was a lie right they
could have lived incredibly good lives
any result of that they all end up
basically turning on the cancerverse
version of read and of course like Susan
storm and one of the coolest moments
ever creates this like force field
bubble around cancer read which
basically like cuts off all of his arms
and a little you know the various
appendages that he has and then in turn
Johnny Storm freaks out Johnny Storm of
course having sided with Reed and saying
Reed made the right choice ends up
incinerating Susan storm you know things
just kind of pop off really really fast
now what you're seeing here in this
instance with cancer versus Johnny Storm
is he's using his Nova flame now the
Nova flame is like the most powerful
weapon that Johnny Storm has right like
literally he goes supernova reaches
about a million degrees Fahrenheit more
than enough to like destroy Ben Graham
and all those various people the idea is
that when Johnny Storm uses it under
normal circumstances it saps all of his
power except for whatever he needs to
live and that's basically it and then of
course it takes him a certain amount of
time to recover what he did here was
basically SAP all of his power now by
all standards of measurement that's why
you know the story is kind of weak to a
degree is that it could basically save
Susan's store like pseudo storm use
their ability to create force fields to
protect the Fantastic Four and we've
seen that work before right I mean she
withstood the power of a celestial
actually have multiple Celestials so it
makes sense she can withstand you know a
million degrees Fahrenheit
I mean that the the shield of Susan
storm is ridiculously difficult to
penetrate the issue is all the other
people who weren't protected and somehow
managed to survive - that's the issue or
the fact of the planet itself managed to
survive it should have been like totally
incinerated right just like caught fire
spontaneous combustion just because of
the sheer temperature that Johnny Storm
from the cancer risk was letting off but
regardless of the circumstance they all
basically end up surviving those
individuals who were around there and
didn't burn up you know by virtue of the
actions of Johnny really kind of end up
combining with the rest of the Fantastic
Four and they continue on their mission
to essentially face often and defeat the
forces of the can servers now from
here we start getting into the good
stuff what this does is the switches
over to a richard rider now when it came
to a nihilist escaping his universe and
the first place he arrived to was the
Nova Corps at least to Richard Ryder
himself right because the ideas of the
Nova Corps was it was a super elite
fighting force before it was totally
obliterated and so showing up here and
looking for help of course as we saw an
annihilation scourge alpha Richard
riders like the only member the Nova
Corps laughing I mean there is Sam
Alexander but there really isn't anybody
else left besides him and so as a result
of that there's not a huge fighting
force to help Annihilus now of course
Annihilus is forces and/or I guess is
his the individual stowed aboard a ship
basically succumb to the infection of
the of the cancerverse
and so there's really no helping them
but Richard Ryder grabbing Annihilus and
then basically grabbing the ship and
pushing it into the Sun and destroying
those those who were infected aboard the
ship what it does is it basically leads
to Annihilus and in Richard Ryder
traveling to earth to try to find the
Fantastic Four the funny thing about
this is that Christos Gage plays it in a
really interesting way when you
essentially have wasn't really in
chrysalis gauges Matthew Rosenberg when
you basically have them show up on the
door of the Fantastic Four and they're
met by the arrival of Franklin and
valerian now here's the funny thing
about this is that Franklin being here
you would expect him to be able to use
his reality-warping powers right because
at this point he's adept enough in his
abilities where you can do all kinds of
different stuff he doesn't instead like
Hillen Valyria pull guns on nova and and
Annihilus it's a smart move because
Franklin's kinda the the trump card for
everything but for those of you guys who
are reading the solicitations that are
coming up from Marvel there's some huge
stuff coming down the line with Franklin
Richards which is why I say the
Fantastic Four I think are gonna be the
next big project before the x-men in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe because of the
fact that Franklin is getting like so
much screen time in your face in Marvel
Comics especially when they're doing
huge events they're gonna be centered
around his character and they're written
in the kind of power he has more any
other funny things that goes on here is
that Annihilus is basically knocked out
by a blast from from Franklin and
valaria and like while he's unconscious
Franklin basically draws a snidely
whiplash mustache on his face they give
him my brows and a mustache
but at the same time they do basically
over open a portal to the negative zone
and send him back through now the
initial thought of Annihilus is that
nova was going to just like drop him off
there and leave him there to die of
course that's not what's gonna happen
that's not what's taking place but once
they get back there is some noble really
beginning to realize how bad things are
because one thing to understand and this
is something that people seem to kind of
lose track of when it comes to the
original fan of severe ative event and
the entry
action of the cancerverse the
cancerverse didn't make it very far into
the universe they didn't conquer that
much in fact they didn't even really
conquer a world a lot of people kind of
tend to forget that and they kind of
seem you know look at the events of the
the cancer versus almost like this
annihilation conquest or an isle
anihilation wave event where like they
get like way out there like most of the
universe's conquer ananka and stuff it
never really gone on that scale never
really got to that level when you look
at the scale for what it was it was
actually pretty small thing compares to
a lot of other things that were going on
and that's exactly what's going on here
right I mean in this universe they've
managed to conquer a huge swath of the
negative zone like a huge portion of the
negative zone so it's far more brave in
terms of the amount of territory has
been conquered by the revenger not only
that of course Annihilus and Nova
managed to find a couple people here and
there on this particular world who have
managed to survive but like that's
basically it right I mean there's not a
whole lot going on there but we do get
this pretty significant revelation right
when they're trapped on this world and
ultimately the crying of a baby
basically draws the forces of the
revenge errs what Richard Rider actually
realizes is that the laws of physics and
the laws of life and death in the
negative zone don't work the same way as
they do in the main Marvel Universe and
so what this means is that when the
individuals in the cancerverse from from
that reality when they're killed in a
negative zone they stay dead right they
don't come back which kind of seems to
fly in the face of what we've seen
before because what we've seen before is
that they've been killed and they got
back up again right so it kind of seems
to be bouncing back and forth in terms
of what's actually going on here but the
overall gist of this is that at the
moment when these forces are destroyed
by Nova that you know with these these
energy beams when they're incinerated
they're gone forever and they're not
coming back why they're not able to make
their return so after that nova goes on
like this warpath right like all these
these various like you know these
cancerous forces that are trying to take
him out like he annihilates them all no
pun intended he destroys them all but as
he makes his way through there and as he
destroys a whole run of these forces
suddenly he comes face to face with
Robert Reynolds and this is the first
time in the history of Marvel Comics
we've actually seen Richard Rider
fight this century and the fight goes
exactly the way you would expect Richard
Rider gets dominated I mean it's not
even fair it's not even funny he gets
crushed like he goes to punch the
century and like this centuries is kind
of like what in the heck
and then when like Richard writer tries
to take off the syndra grabs his foot
and just like smashes him into the
ground and then like that's basically it
like Richard writers defeated that
quickly
of course this allows the other Avengers
to come in you know the Captain America
Avenger and
and Carol Danvers and so on but of
course that basically leads to him you
know kind of getting out while he can
ultimately it's really believed by the
forces of Annihilus that like Richard
Ryder had abandoned them right you know
he kind of you know uses this device to
basically travel back into the main male
universe in the negative zone and they
believe that he's basically taking off
on that's kind of an important thing
right that's that's the cool thing about
stories like this is you get to see
these encounters that you would never
normally really see whether you would
never never see were these various
characters and meeting each other you
only get to see that see that go down so
of course this leads to basically Silver
Surfer now after the events of Silver
Surfer block and I don't think it's
explicitly stated in the story as to why
but after the events of Silver Surfer
black where he was basically thrown all
the way back to the very beginning of
all Rio of all creation before the
universe was made in the realm that was
occupied by and all the symbiotes God
which I thought about covering but I was
like I got I got other stuff that I want
to do but then you know instead of that
but when he was thrown all the way back
there ultimately he ended up finally
being brought back to the main Marvel
Universe and the present time but he's
essentially almost intangible right like
things can't really touch it he's almost
like a specter like a phantom things
passed through him but watching all
these things go down watching these
forces of the negative zone basically
come pouring out to these various
portals like literally just fleeing from
their universe then is just kind of like
what in the world is happening here
right so he basically ends up passing
through the rift and entering in the
negative zone himself and just sees like
essentially the cancerverse has returned
now for Silver Surfer it's time to panic
server server's face off against this
before right so he understands its the
severity of the threat that the
cancerverse represents that if it's
allowed to basically get out and if it's
allowed to spread throughout the rest of
the universe it'll destroy everything in
its path right I mean it'll just kill
and annihilate everything that comes
across and so Silver Surfer on nothing
can really touch him he can't touch
things but only with energy blast right
not with physical punches or anything
and so these various forces the negative
zone are dealt with pretty quickly and
that's basically it you know that kind
of dealt with pretty quickly and harshly
but what he picks up on is that there's
something out there in the rubble that's
basically hiding and when he travels
through and he ends up locating it he
ends up finding Robert Reynolds now
again as you guys who are familiar with
the century are aware of that you have
three versions right you got the century
you've got Robert Reynolds and you've
got the void by they're three distinct
different personalities and what he does
here is he basically kind of fills in
the gaps from where the Fantastic Four
the Fantastic Four explanation left out
what we're told here is that once Robert
Reynolds left and went into the negative
zone that what he ended up doing was
basically
absorbing all the negative zone
antimatter
energies that were there now of course
antimatter versus positive matter
basically can lead to a kind of
explosion on the atomic level I mean I'm
not super well knowledgeable about
physics so I'm not 100% sure about like
the properties of matter versus
antimatter and how it all ties together
I mean you know I'm as good looking up a
Wikipedia article as anybody else is but
I'm not gonna like espouse it as gospel
truth but the idea here is it
essentially what this did is it either
force the void to split with Robert
Reynolds or it allow the void to leave
regardless of the circumstances the void
Amen Robert Reynolds in the century were
separated and so with this version of
Bob Reynolds that you have here what you
basically have is Robert Reynolds in the
century in a singular being and then
you've got the void out there who's the
one that we saw fighting on Nova and so
on and so forth they took on the the
perception of the physical appearance of
the century and it just kind of been
like that you know this entire time in
the negative zone and so the result of
this is that silver surfer basically
looking at Robert Reynolds is saying
okay all this seems system from you then
you and I are basically going to team up
and so what he is up doing is basically
grabbing Robert Reynolds you know kind
of reaching into him and then absorbing
Robert Reynolds in the century into
himself and so in effect this century
becomes a silver surfer even looks like
it right he's got like the cape and he's
got the belt with the S on it he's got
the hair and everything which is awesome
actually not from here it picks up with
beta ray bill and the beta ray bill
story is actually pretty legit right
like it's pretty amazing because what
you get is basically beta ray bill it's
kind of funny beta ray bill was on this
world what does this guy King Cyrus I
think is what his name was and
ultimately like they believe that beta
ray bill was getting bored and they
thought he was gonna leave and so what
he did is basically engineered this
whole ruse and there's even like a guy
dressed up as a monster which is all
kind of goofy looking and beta ray bills
like tis some form of trickery but
basically like when there was an actual
threat and the world was was basically
saved suddenly like this rift begins to
open up right almost you know very
reminiscent to the one that we saw from
the original introduction of the
cancerverse in the Thanos imperative
story and as soon as that happens
basically you kind of switch back over
to the negative zone and you have like
all these forces these negative zone
forces trying to basically stave off the
many angled one forces right the
cancerous forces and then in turn trying
to make sure that nothing passes through
the rift as well as some trying to make
their escape now as that happens and ask
some of the forces make their way
through suddenly like the main Marvel
Universe is met by the arrival of the
cancerverse Doctor Strange now this is
kind of a cool theme because when this
goes down is basically Doctor Strange
versus beta ray bill which again is one
of these these interesting little
onca these interesting little battles do
we haven't really seen before the
problem with this is one of the
cancerverse forces makes a mistake of
when they go to attack beta ray bill
that lockjaw jumps in the way right like
lockjaw basically being the dog that is
part of the Inhumans and him and beta
ray bill have apparently been friends
for a very long time and gone on a lot
of adventures together essentially they
heard a man's dog and as anybody who
owns a dog will tell you when you heard
a man's dog you got to pay the price and
the price is your life where is that
guy's life anyway so literally like beta
ray bill destroys that guy and then in
turn goes on a warpath and like destroys
that version of Doctor Strange and it
happens fast I mean it's not even like
this long drawn-out battle it's a
one-page thing like Doctor Strange goes
to blast beta ray bill beta ray bill
deflects the blast using his uh
Stormbreaker hammer and then runs up on
Doctor Strange is just like smashes and
that's basically yet like Doctor Strange
is taken out and so what he ends up
doing is talking to the cancer to the -
one of the forces of Annihilus who
basically explains what we've been
talking about this whole time well I
thought like the negative zones being
overrun and the and so on so forth you
know and so when the questions asks like
this rift was not there before right so
basically meaning somebody managed to
take this portal that the this is this
little bitty portal that was there
before it was closing down after an
eyeless had passed through it to
ultimately find Nova so idea managed to
grab this portal and begin ripping it
open so they essentially ripped a hole
in the fabric of space who was it that
did this and of course that's when this
this guy basically says it was the
century and so what you end up having is
beta ray bill who goes charging headlong
against the century and just like Noah
before him beta ray bill gets decimated
but he gets destroyed Bam Bam Bam he's
totally outmatched and totally out fast
and it makes sense right because with
the century it's really even just with a
void cuz it's not only the century but
with the void it's not just strength
that you're facing off against its
astronomical speed right I mean it's
like faster than Lightspeed it's it's
ridiculous fighting speed that you that
he's facing off against here and so this
fight was essentially over before it
even started right and that's what
though that's what the void says right
like this is a fight you can't win don't
even try and ultimately that's exactly
how it goes down right like beta Rho
beta ray bill takes storm breaker and
basically throws it at at the void eros
throws the century and sends him flying
back through the portal right at the
time when the when the the dimensional
rift is closing up basically meaning
that the hammer gets stuck in the
negative zone where the century is sent
back and so as result of that beta ray
bill is basically transformed back into
his korbinite form and then ultimately
just kind of okay we got to find a way
to get my hammer back we have to find a
way to get into the negative zone and
then basically help to defeat those
forces and so that's exactly
what happens beta ray bill alongside
lockjaw this we passed through this
dimensional rift right at the mode that
it closes and they're in the negative
zone as well so what it does is it
creates that you know in the
annihilation scourge Omega line it
creates this kind of coming together of
of Silver Surfer century along with Nova
and beta ray bill and the Fantastic Four
which is cool to see this whole thing go
down right because when you pick up into
this it's basically the the negative
zone incursion day plus 74 days right so
it's been 75 days since this whole thing
first started and so with that going
down like as they get in there the
Fantastic Four kind of off doing their
own thing or at least you know traveling
over to kind of see if they can't find
some way to find where the source of
this threat is or whatever the case is
kind of picking up from where their
story left off and there's like this
huge smoldering you know pile out in the
distance and once they travel over to it
they end up finding like beta ray bill
just searching for his hammer and then
in turn ultimately finding it now of
course this at the same time this
happens then you get the arrival of the
Silver Surfer century right so this is
over century is I want to call them
which is an awesome name now that I
think about it you know but nonetheless
like it's these these forces kind of
coming together and then like destroying
these cancer risk forces pretty quickly
right I mean they get it dealt with
pretty fast but it's kind of a coming
together in like hey what are you doing
here what are you doing here not only
that we actually end up finding out that
the the Fantastic Four have been using
prison 42 as their base of operations
and Susan storm has been keeping a big
heating and invisible now those two guys
who don't know prison 42 was actually
created by Reed Richards in the negative
zone as a prison for people who refuse
to saw in the superhuman Registration
Act during the events of civil war right
so this goes back really really really
far but essentially Susan storm had made
like the entire planet invisible not
only that all those various forces who
have been trying to find trying to find
refuge right who have been refugees
escaping their worlds and in the the
face of like this incursion from the
cancerverse kind of conquering world
after world after world have basically
taken up residence here and is and it's
interesting because it's like they're
trying to survive right they're trying
to live and this was really the only
absolute safe refuge left in the
entirety the negative zone because it's
it's what the the cancerverse members
cannot see right they can't see it and
they cannot detect it such as the power
of Susan storms ability to make things
invisible and so once I kind of get this
whole thing organized and structured
who's gonna be doing what and then how
everything is unfolding suddenly Susan
storm passes out and the reason why is
because her ability to maintain this
invisibility of the planet is suddenly
shook when we end up finding out the
void is literally punching on the
invisibility of the planet as
well as the shield that Susan storm is
using to keep it protected and now yet
that's the power of the void right I
mean the void is one of these things
where you don't really see his full
totality the full power of the void was
really put on display and the what-if
story for siege where basically the void
killed all the superheroes on earth and
then went out into the universe and
conquered and like destroyed the
universe right like that's when you
really see like the full totality of the
voids powers but you don't see it all
that often and not only that what you
end up doing is is in the middle of all
this when it's all going to pot and the
fear is that the void is going to punch
through suddenly the negative zone
portal activates and then in comes
Richard Rider with the entire Imperial
Guard and like a whole host of
superheroes and see this is the reason
why Richard Rider is so cool he knows
all the right people to gather if things
pop off that's why it's awesome to have
him on your side right because Richard
ride of his fought alongside pretty much
everybody
and so there's anybody that you want to
have there when it comes to forming like
a universal team you want Richard Rider
there one because you'll fight to the
end and - he knows which allies to call
in based on various threats but using
the forces are really bringing in all
these other Universal forces as well as
Nova himself alongside the silver
century with the Fantastic Four and with
beta ray bill they really start to like
decimate all these hand servers of
soldiers who were there the issue is
they haven't found the source and until
they do the cancerverse will continue
flooding in in the same way that it
always has it'll continue passing in
over and over and over and over again
and so what is up going on here is that
with the century being there basically
you end up having the Silver Surfer who
just Rams to the century and basically
the the Robert Reynolds century aspect
of himself merges with a void so they go
back to being the way they were before
and then of course is kind of a kind of
a return kind of a state of normalcy
everything sort of balances out only
insofar as like Robert Reynolds on the
void go right I mean they're they're
basically back to being the merged
version of the character that you saw at
the end of Jeff lemierre's run and so as
a result of that now the question
becomes how do we stop the the forces of
like the cancerous right because all
this is done is fixed the century but it
hasn't fixed the source of the problem
and so you kind of get this this really
cool revelation when Richard Ryder takes
off you know to go find the source of
this whole thing along with the Silver
Surfer who follows them and you kind of
get this explanation that what had gone
on here is that when Robert Reynolds and
the void had split it he created a rift
in the negative zone itself such as the
power of the void right to disperse that
much power in such a shorter and kind of
like an explosion of sorts literally
ripped a hole in the negative zone which
opened access to the cancer burst and I
remember
one of the things we've talked about
before is how the multiverse works in
regards to the negative zone that where
you do have all these different
universes that are out there for all the
universes that are there there's only
one negative zone and all those
universes can access the negative zone
and so what it basically means is that
it's literally a hallway of doors and in
this instance when Robert Reynolds split
from the void he opened the door to the
cancerverse
and all those folks came flooding in
right and so with that being the case
that the cancerverse itself is really
kind of kind of shown as sort of like
this entity trying to push its way
through now this entity is one of the
many angled ones and if you remember the
original story there was no top angled
one right there wasn't like a mini
angled one that all the other mini
angled ones were beholden to it was just
the mini angled ones were like these
demonic entities and they were the ones
who started the cancerverse
with that being the case Richard Ryder
actually makes the sacrifice you know as
the second time he's done it you know
but he basically makes the sacrifice and
saying okay so he absorbs the entirety
of the cancerverse
into himself which basically leads to to
the century destroying Richard Ryder and
the cancer verse seemingly along with it
and so with Richard Ryder being
completely destroyed here my initial
thought was do they really just kill
Richard lighter and like some kind of
one-off miniseries is that really how
they're gonna kill Richard Ryder cousin
like the Thanos imperative he went out
like a hero man did he do it was it was
amazing like it was it was him and it
was Peter quill with a cosmic cube and
you didn't know what happened until
Richard Ryder came back later on right
it was kind of like and they're done now
and that was basically it
and it was just kind of like wow like
that's nuts so it was it was a really
amazing ending but the guy went out like
a hero I was like this is it he's gonna
absorb like whatever this entity is is
trying to get into the negative zone and
then close down the portal to the cancer
verse and then that's basically it it
was it was kind of disappointing but
ultimately what ends up happening is
that with with Richard Ryder's body
being destroyed it creates almost this
kind of black hole as a portal begins to
shut down now everybody manages to make
it out but then like literally you have
this page that comes up and says and
just like that it ended and it was just
kind of like okay so basically like the
day is saved you know by the sacrifice
of Richard Rider this century is still
kind of healthier doing his own thing uh
and they they really just kind of make
it make a cheer to Nova you know I
already sort of celebrating the actions
of Nova and the sacrifice that he made
but it's a cool theme because then you
you kind of switch over to the negative
zone where you have Nova who's basically
brought back Richard Rider is
resurrected by a nihilist he's in the
same technology they use on Johnny Storm
in order to bring him back and then he
tells the Richard rider in the Silver
Surfer
to get out of his universe and then the
story ends right so like definitely the
weakest ending ever
history of a miniseries it was car
disappointing ah but that's basically it
annihilation skirt it'sa it's an
open-and-shut story right is it's really
really self-contained and that's
basically yeah I think the Inman could
have been infinitely better and I feel
like it was kind of rushed if I'm being
honest I felt like the ending was kind
of rushed I don't feel like it was
supposed to end this way it's kind of
disappointing that it did but you know
again that's just kind of the nature of
the beast when it comes to stories like
this so with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to come this explain to
make sure you guys have the sub button
to become part of the Rob core if you
guys enjoyed this video make sure you
drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]
[Music]